cricket always feels better when the
stumps are in the middle the sun is out
and play is underway
but the racism scandal is still playing
out in yorkshire with the county cricket
club itself now charged with bringing
the game into disrepute the allegations
go back to 2004. felt isolated
humiliated at times
former player azeem rafiq laid out to
mps how racism had blighted his and so
many other careers
cricket had to act
rafiq who could still be disciplined
himself over his own anti-semitism
welcomed the charges he said this has
been another grueling but unfortunately
necessary process it's been a long two
years since i went public about my
experiences but i hope this all means
that no young player ever goes through
such pain and alienation again
young players here in bradford and in
all corners of the uk
need a more equal and accessible sport
certainly at grassroots levels we you
know we've actually yet to see any
changes any positive changes have
actually happened some individuals and
some organizations have done quite well
out of the changes that happen but again
people working at the grassroots levels
we're still waiting for something to
happen
at headingley it's been a painful
process lord patel came in 16 members of
staff were sacked some of whom have now
won their cases of unfair dismissal and
now all-rounder david willey has quit
saying the club is too fixated on
repairing its reputation
the new sponsors here are called clean
slate
next week they'll be hosting
international test cricket here once
again a sign that significant progress
has been made but racism and archaic
attitudes don't just disappear overnight
because an organization wants them to
this is a well-supported proud
institution and that brings a range of
thinking through the gates if you go on
to the terraces and in the the stands
are heading me now
yeah you still hear
a denial right there's a very strong
denial that i am institutionally racist
the club might be but but i'm not and
that's an educational issue that people
aren't necessarily grasping what that
means
those charged will have their cases
heard in the autumn some deny any
wrongdoing but the ecb is standing by
its promises to act on racism within the
game
tom parmenter sky news west yorkshire